it's a vaccine that's most likely to
bring an end to the pandemic
and that depends on people like john
he's in good health but knows many
others who aren't and now wants to help
test experimental vaccines so they can
be rolled out as quickly as possible to
those who need them the most
some of my friends in this age group are
not being so lucky they've got
underlying health conditions
i've got grandchildren who i'm hoping
will go back to school in september
that's going to increase the exposure so
i think anything i can do
that will bring forward a usable vaccine
is something that i really should do
more than 100
000 people have so far signed up to the
covid19
vaccine research registry a database of
volunteers
but many more will be needed as
large-scale clinical trials start this
autumn
to help test whether prototype vaccines
can protect against the virus
older patients and those from black
asian and minority ethnic backgrounds
are particularly needed
when a vaccine comes it is very
important that this is the vulnerable
population
we want to vaccinate but we need to make
sure that the trials produce a desirable
risk
result in this population so that when a
vaccine gets licensed
eventually we know that it could work in
that population two vaccine studies are
currently running in the uk
one in oxford another in london but at
least
10 are expected to start between
september and the end of the year
signing people up to a registry now
should speed up the trials
well that took a matter of minutes to
enter some basic personal details and
give a little bit of my medical history
if i meet the criteria for a study
running in my area a researcher will now
get in touch they tell me a little bit
more about the clinical trial
i get to ask some questions and only
then do i consent to take part
vaccines have never been developed at
such a rapid pace
but those in charge say that doesn't
mean researchers are taking
shortcuts the mhra which is the
regulator in the uk
has very very high as as they should
high standards for safety those safety
studies are not being compressed they're
not being changed there's no difference
in how
new vaccines are being evaluated in for
this pandemic versus any other
vaccine or therapeutics if the trials go
well on volunteers like john
a vaccine could be approved by medical
regulators towards the end of the year
then rolled out to frontline health and
care workers and high-risk patients
soon after thomas more sky news